الينا من القاهره السيد عبد الواحد محمد
الخبير في الامن القومي والعلاقات الدوليه
ارحب بك سيد عبد الواحد بدايه هل هو فعلا
حدث عربي ام ان هناك مصلحه فعليه لروسيا
في اسقاط الطائره الامريكيه المسيره
اهلا بحضرتك واهلا بضيوفك واهلا بضيفك
الكريم اولا ملابسات الحادث غير معروفه
حتى الان بسبب تعدد الاقوال الاقوال او او
النص الروسي يختلف تماما عن الامريكي
امريكي ترى انه حادث متهور من قبل
المقاتلتين الامريكيتين واعترضوا هذه
الطائره وانا اتشكك فيها في الاول لان من
الصعب جدا ان تقوم طائره مقاتله بالاصطدام
بطياره مسيره لان ممكن انها تكون فيها
اسلحه او متفجرات وبالتالي عمل مجنون عمل
غير طبيعي الحاجه التانيه روسيا بتقول ان
ده عمل استفزازي وان هذه الطائره المسيره
اقتربت من شبه جزيره القرم واقتربت من
اهداف روسيه موجوده في المنطقه اخي الفاضل
احب ان اشير ان هذا الحادث له بوادين بعد
عسكري وبعد سياسي البعد العسكري بيتمثل ان
عمليه الاعتراض هي ليست من نوعها
وكما ذكرت كمان يعني المتحدث الامريكي
للامن القومي ان هناك عمليات ظهرت من قبل
خلال اسبوعين ولكن هذه العمليه هي الاقوى
تاثيرا كما ان روسيا الحقيقه حدث فيها
عمليتين من قبل في شهر ديسمبر الماضي
طياره مسيره اوكرانيه سقطت في بالقرب من
احد المطارات الجويه الروسيه وفي شهر
فبراير الماضي اثنين طائره مسيره
انفجروا بالقرب من مستودعات للطاقه اذا
عمليه الاصطدام مباشره ما بين الاطراف
اثنين تاني حاجه ان
الدعم الامريكي والغربي
لاوكرانيا لم يقتصر فقط على تقديم معونات
سلاح او دعم مادي او تدريب ولكن كمان
بيشمل عمليات المراقبه الجويه وعمليات
التجسس والعمليات الاستخباراتيه يعني هو
بيدعمه
العديد من المعلومات الاستخباراتيه سواء
من خلال الاعمار الصناعيه او من خلال هذه
الطائره ام كيو تسعه ام كيو 9 من الطائرات
الهامه والطائرات ذات التقنيه العاليه
سواء لديها اجهزه استشعار اجهزه مراقبه
تستطيع القيام بعمليات قتاليه بدقه عاليه
خاصه مع التوجيه
الليزر
النقطه الثالثه في الشق العسكري ان هذه
الطائره كانت بتطير فوق الاجواء الدوليه
ودي الحقيقه هتسبب مشكله كبيره اجواء
دوليه يعني هل روسيا هتحرم الولايات
المتحده انها تحلق في الاجواء الجويه
الدوليه هذا منافي لقواعد القانون الدوله
السؤال الذي اردت بشكل ما اطرحه عليك هو
هل هناك رساله من روسيا من خلال اسقاط هذه
الطائره او سقوط هذه الاطار هل هناك من
رسائل ترسلها موسكو واشنطن وهل هذا الحدث
قد يؤدي الى تصعيد في المستقبل على خلفيه
سقوط هذه المسيره
طبعا هناك رسائل متعدده ان ان سقوط
الطائره بيحرم الولايات المتحده الامريكيه
وشركائها من الغرب في التحليق في المياه
الجويه او في الاجواء الدوليه
القريبه المتاخمه لروسيا وده طبعا شيء زي
ما قلت لحضرتك مخالف للقانون الدولي اثنين
ان كمان في امكانيه انها تحصل لروسيا على
حطام هذه الطائره ويتم تفكيكها والتعرف
على اجهزه الاستشعار واجهزه المراقبه
وبالتالي توظف هذا الحادث لاغراض سياسيه
على انه انتصار على التكنولوجيا الامريكيه
اللي موجوده في المنطقه كمان
هذا الحادث له بعد سياسي لانه جيب التزامن
مع تصريحات الكريملين الخاصه بعمليات
استمرار العمليات العسكريه وان روسيا لم
تحقق اهدافها بعد في اوكرانيا وبتدعو الى
استمرار العمليات العسكريه سيدي الفاضل
هناك حاله من التوتر
الشديد بين الاطراف الحرب كلما طالت كلما
زادت حده التوتر سواء من الجانب الامريكي
وانا شايف ان حتى الامريكان في حاله من
الاضطراب وحاله من الارتباك لاني بيحاول
يفتح كمان سياسيا بيحاول يفتح جبهات اخرى
سواء في منطقه الشرق الاوسط او في منطقه
الصين بالتزامن مع حرب اوكرانيه وحاله
ارتباك ايضا داخل الكرملين بسبب بدايه
تصاعد الاصوات
والقلق من اطاله امد الحرب وخسائر بشريه
كبيره جدا لم تحدث من قبل والداخل كمان
ملتهب ولكن لا يستطيع ان يتحدث
بجراءه او يتحدث بصوره علنيه لظروف سياسيه
في روسيا كل الشكر لك سيد عبد الواحد محمد
الخبير في الامن القومي للعلاقات الدوليه
كنت معنا من القاهره شكرا